it's six o'clock this is sky news we are
live from buckian palace on the final
day of national celebrations for the
queen's platinum jubilee
your majesty
mummy prince charles pays tribute to the
queen for a lifetime of service
you have met us and talked with us
you laugh and cry with us
and most importantly
you have been there for us for these 70
years
[Music]
well the royals sing along as tens of
thousands celebrate outside buckian
palace and millions more watch on tv
the queen didn't attend but she still
stole the show finally revealing what is
in her handbag
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
keep mine in here
well this afternoon the four-day royal
extravaganza culminates in a pageant
with thousands of performers parading
through central london
and party like it's 1952 communities
across the country are expected to come
together for jubilee street parties
also to come this morning in the sport
it's a huge day for wales who have the
chance to make a first world cup finals
appearance in 64 years when they take on
ukraine this afternoon
and we'll have a look at just how the
morning's newspapers are reporting the
jubilee including of course all that
coverage of last night's brilliant party
at the palace
[Music]
good morning from buckingham palace on
the fourth and final day of national
celebrations for the queen's platinum
jubilee it is great to be here at our
ringside seat and to have you with us as
well what a show last night good times
never felt so good for thousands of
royal fans who filled them out for last
night's concert even prince william was
swaying along to rod stewart and sweet
caroline well one of the most memorable
moments of the night was when charles
came on stage to pay tribute to his
mother
he said you laugh and cry with us and
most importantly have been there for us
for these 70 years but of course the
star of the show was the queen herself
our royal correspondent rhiannon mills
reports
the party atmosphere had built up early
thousands again filling the mouth and
the woman they all wanted to see had
recorded a special welcome
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
i always keep one for emergencies
so do i
i keep mine in here
for
later was up to queen to follow that
20 years after performing on the roof of
buckingham palace for her golden jubilee
where on earth do you go from the roof
well you will see
somewhere different yeah we've been
working on it for months it's very hard
not to talk about it actually it's hard
to keep that secret but yeah we have an
interesting
new place to go she wasn't here in
person this time but her family were to
watch a concert for every generation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from pop to rock musicals to ballet
everyone wanting to pay their tribute
two years ago i was singing in the
corner of my shed no idea that this
would happen or like eurovision or
anything i had no idea what was in store
like for my little path in music and um
i'm just here so grateful and elated to
be part of something like this she's a
constant in our lives i feel like i've
she's been over my shoulder since i was
a kid because we're nearly the same age
alongside hot royalty prince william
also took the stage to celebrate the
legacy of a woman who continues to guide
them all
it's my firm hope
that my grandmother's words
are as true in 70 years time as they are
tonight
that as nations we come together in
common cause
because then there is always room for
hope
tonight has been full of such optimism
and joy and there is hope
but it was his father and her heir who
tried to express what the queen means to
so many with the warmest of words
your majesty
mommy
you have met us and talked with us
you laugh and cry with us
and most importantly
you have been there for us for these 70
years
the star of the show was of course
resting in windsor the crowds hoping she
might be back for the final day of
celebrations as they couldn't make it
any clearer how much the monarch and
this moment means to them
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace
one incredible night it was uh it does
feel like the morning after the night
before we are joined by the royal
historian ed this morning tessa dunlop i
am glad to say um any particular
highlights for you yeah i mean i can't
believe this is the same place
watching it on telly i think was that an
illusion if you come here and it's like
yeah everyone's a bit bedraggled yeah
it's like empty coffee cups
green part desperately looking to have a
facelift um there were so many standout
moments the whole thing was a bit of an
endurance course i'm kind of glad the
queen wasn't there little george and we
focus always on the queen you know in
her great age but there were tiny tots
there really george had been up to
cardiff earlier that day i saw him
waving in from from a carriage looking
really embarrassed on the thursday and
he did have quite big bags under his arm
oh bless him i mean a lot of people were
hoping to see louie as well weren't they
little louis but i guess he was just too
young for a bit of a big show yeah just
in bed probably but i thought it was
i mean obviously it was a big
celebration of british news we had brian
men and sparkly silver and rod stewart
this bouncing ego will he ever go back
in his box i don't think so
in sort of mustard yellow knocking it
out and then
you saw the heir to the throne and um
prince william who will of course also
one day be king stand up and speak for
their grandmother and it was interesting
you realize it gets easier as you get
older william what kind of role do you
take as a 40 year old man it's you know
it's a pop concert and he came across as
a bit of a dad really you know a bit
slightly awkward banged on about the
environment no bad thing if boris
johnson's in the audience but perhaps a
touch earnest and my 13 year old noticed
he said mankind not humankind oh dear
but i think the prize of the night has
to go to prince charles really moving he
gets the laughs he feels more
comfortable and that public school
affectation mummy i mean
everyone just kind of
loved it they're sort of the nation
erupted in a little chuckle didn't their
belly lie it was like unexpected wasn't
it the mummy but then it did come across
as very genuine as well i mean i think
as he'd knocked out in one of the
earlier jubilees i mean we've been
through a few now um
he realized it's now his shtick it is
interesting it's a sort of hangover from
times gone by when children like charles
wrenched away from their parents when
they still did call the mummy and they
hold on to it and if you look at royal
letters going back uh through the
decades they do use these terms mommy
and daddy that most of us give up when
we're well in senior school
that's that is true
lovely to chat and i'm really glad to
have you here throughout the morning
we'll have lots more to talk about i'm
sure last night but also of course
looking ahead to the events later today
let's have a look at how the morning's
front pages are describing last night's
festivities shall we now
we can start with the telegraph and it
photographs the queen's wonderful tea
party with paddington bear probably my
personal highlight which featured of
course in last night's concert that's
also the image on the front of the times
it calls the event the party of a
lifetime for the world's grandmother
marmalade your majesty asks the male get
it
and then the sun goes with intruder at
the palace making light of paddington
bear's surprise appearance alongside
the queen
let's have a look at the express now
that quotes prince charles's speech from
last night's concert thank you for being
there for us mummy
and the daily mirror features the other
queen brian may who performed for the
royals in front of buckingham palace
and the observer describes the jubilee
festivities as a long weekend and a
carnival of memory
great coverage there while the
celebrations of course culminate in
today's platinum jubilee pageant lots to
look forward to let's just give you a
quick rundown of what to expect it
starts outside the palace of westminster
then the procession heads up through
whitefall past number 10 and other
government buildings as well
it then takes a turn at trafalgar square
going past nelson's column before
heading through admiral tree arch
coming out onto the mall it then travels
towards the queen victoria monument
that's the one outside buckingham palace
before turning onto bird cage walk
alongside james's park to clear the way
for those behind
the three kilometer route will be led by
the gold state coach now this is a 260
year old carriage that carried the queen
to and from her coronation all the way
back in 1953
and it starts at 2 30 p.m so you don't
want to miss that and it will be a
spectacle divided into four different
acts so at one is a military display
it's titled for queen and country so all
three services are marching to honor
their commander-in-chief and they'll be
joined by the armed forces of the
commonwealth as well
act two is called the time of our lives
and it showcases how british life has
really changed over the queen's reign
let's celebrate is a festival of street
theater urban dance and carnival
performances
should be a particularly fun element
that and then the final act is happy and
glorious as the performers come to a
stop outside buckian palace with some
music from ed sheeran
the platinum pageant uh concludes in a
rendition of the national anthem that's
performed by gospel choir and the band
of her majesty's royal marines
well with us this morning is the royal
historian ertessa dunlop let's go back
to tasha shall we it should be quite
spectacular later yeah i was thinking
which gig is more of a compliment to be
asked to close
the whole jubilee weekend like ed
sheeran has been or to be out there
rocking it like brian may and rod stu i
i'm kind of betwixt in between on that
one i mean both pretty good uh slots you
have to say they're kind of headline
slots for both ones right do you suppose
anyone turned it down i was listening to
one of the organizers last night um on
the radio and she admitted yeah there
were a few diva requests but she
wouldn't divulge which i would love to
know that maybe like a bit of sleuthing
in the next couple of days i think so
it'll come out i think it's interesting
though isn't it just how long she's
reigned for because of course the music
didn't really even touch on her
favorites obviously vera lynn who we
recently quite recently lost actually
fred astaire you know this
you know even the old stuff is would
have been to the to the queen would seem
like a sort of beyond contemporary yeah
that's extraordinary bandwidth and i
thought sometimes the royal box looked
like they didn't really feel too
connected with the music and no big
surprise i mean it requires a sort of
70-year catalogue and enthusiasm yeah
that's true you have to keep up to date
as well i wonder if that will be a bit
different with the pageant because it
does feel like elements of the pageant
are reflecting you know how society has
changed some of the sort of celebrities
perhaps
from years gone by as well yeah also
it's a pick and mix and it's less static
you know where you're standing depending
where you're viewing it you're
experiencing something different i love
the idea of that state coaches the third
oldest in britain um under george the
third and it's been i think refurb
something like seven times can you
imagine the sort of layers of gold paint
don't trip it i was about to say chip it
away but don't don't don't hear it don't
do that but of course and the hologram
or the sort of you know extraordinary
images of the queen that are going to be
waving from the window i mean the
million dollar question i guess is will
we see her
in
in person and i guess we don't know that
at this point
one is hoping she's been saving herself
to come out and close it she certainly
saved herself to be there three times on
the opening day and fingers crossed that
she will close it out of course it's not
just her that was absent yesterday i
thought the sussex says could have come
and checked in on the concert but then i
guess it's difficult for them though
isn't it because it's they're sort of
found if they do damned if they don't
because then if they were there
prominently then all the papers this
morning you know and probably you know
the conversation as well
we would be stealing the show we'd be
analyzing the body language it feels
like there's been something some pretty
careful choreography yeah going on about
their interactions with the rest of the
world and are we meant to be thinking
that perhaps they and their one-year-old
daughter a little bit were sharing the
marmalade sandwich with the queen in
windsor last night oh wow that's a very
good point absolutely that is a good
point be interesting to know meeting her
for the first time as well and they have
to be seen of course on her first
birthday as hands-on parents because to
remember that there's been criticism and
wanting to do things differently we
talked just a moment ago about charles
going off to boarding school and being
separated from a really early age even
earlier than boarding school from his
mother because she was always on tour
and so forth so this is a different way
of doing it hands-on yeah definitely
different um
lots more from you as the program
continues so now you could describe the
queen's 70-year reign as a journey from
jelly to pakora well britain today is
much more diverse than it was in the
1950s and that will be reflected when
communities across the country come
together today to celebrate the jubilee
and what hasn't changed much is
weather
let's really hope the rain does stay off
it feels like it's a kind of jubilee
tradition that it has to pull down
let's listen now to laura bundock
from bournemouth's bunting on coronation
day
to burton joyce in nottinghamshire
we've long marked the monarch's
milestones britain jubilant joyful and
just a little eccentric
this is the village of horsted canes in
west sussex the year
1953 the children all dressed up for the
occasion
not much has changed today with events
taking place on the same green i love
fancy dress
and this film inspiring the platinum
party planners it's just nice to just
bring it all bring everyone back
together again especially after what's
been happening the last few years
everyone really needs it
you know just to all of us to just pull
together and have some nice time really
so to make the bunting this is what i
did last time from sussex to sheffield
it's just a matter of stapling it to the
string lisa moorman's streets making
bunting i just remember everyone being
so excited here she is in
1977 enjoying the silver jubilee they
had all of the street parties they got
all the children out and it was just a
great occasion i remember that and
hopefully let's do something similar for
our children to remember to pass on to
theirs
this park in preston's promising
england's biggest party a mellow and
multicultural meal for 600.
preston is so diverse it's got a lot of
final different ethnic minority
community groups
in
in the location so it was important to
reflect the residents of preston to be
here and let them feel part of this
national celebration some streets saw
the forecast and brought their parties
forward a day
waterproof bunting here in shirley
they've been buying waterproofs and
umbrellas
we're just improvising with as much uh
plastic above head as possible that we
can get on a budget
because it's gonna be a real shame if
people just sort of come and everyone's
huddled under their umbrellas and
looking all miserable we want everyone
to be happy
whatever the weather parties are playing
out across the uk remembering and
reminiscing 70 years of rain
laura bundock sky news in horstead
keynes
i really hope the rain does hold off
those jubilee parties it looks pretty
ominous here i have to say but of course
the jubilee isn't the only big event
this weekend the last time that wales
qualified for the world cup prince
charles was still at primary school and
the beatles hadn't even been formed and
of course it as well as bad luck that
tonight nearly everyone who isn't welsh
is probably going to be hoping it stays
that way because they are taking on
ukraine for a place at qatar 2022. after
johnson reports
when wales line up against ukraine
support in this household will be split
maria and her son robert have been
getting used to life in cardiff
they left ukraine six weeks ago to live
with sarah and her family in wales but
the mutual support they share will be
tested for 90 minutes maria will be at
the match cheering ukraine
so emotions so
very big i think i will be happy and i
believe ukrainian team
will be win
uh one man said
in sunday we are not friend but in
monday we will be friend again
for wales though the stakes are high the
players preparing to fight for a place
in the world cup for the first time in
over 60 years
but to get there they'll need to beat
aside who'll have support from around
the world if we could take away what
they're going through in a heartbeat we
absolutely would every single one of the
staff and players
now this is business and that's it it's
not spoken about in camp
this is an opportunity for wales for us
to qualify to uh for a world cup and and
full focus is on that
at this pub in cardiff memories from
euro 2016 when wales reached the
semi-finals and tributes to their star
player as the nation hopes gareth bale
and the team can build on recent success
in the euros
but eight-year-old james and his dad are
nervous
i'm feeling a little bit
scared about ukraine beating us not in
my lifetime we've been in the world cup
so i think um obviously after the euros
and the excitement of what wales
football have done yeah fingers crossed
if the result doesn't go our way i don't
think anybody over ukraine would go into
the world cup finals in you know in the
current situation which is
absolutely tragic the ukraine side are
fresh from victory in scotland they came
out fighting midweek for their first
game since their country was invaded
team and manager determined to give
their country something to celebrate
for both teams it'll be emotional as
they kick off here in cardiff wales are
used to being the popular underdogs in
big matches but this time they'll feel
the support of the world against them as
they try to do what no welsh team has
achieved for more than six decades
a win would mean the world to welsh fans
but who would want to bet against
ukraine in this game of survival becky
johnson sky news cardiff
good morning you're watching sky news
breakfast right here from our ringside
seat at buckian palace let's have a look
now at our top stories
prince charles pays tribute to the queen
for a lifetime of service at a concert
in her honor
the queen didn't attend but she still
stole the show in a surprise appearance
with another british icon
the platinum jubilee celebrations will
draw to a close with a colourful street
pageant today with thousands of
performers parading through central
london
now it really was at some concert last
night i'm sure everyone will have at
their own personal favorite moment with
the rock band queen two future kings
taking to the stage alongside of course
a whole host of other stars as well now
prince william used the occasion to call
for some urgent action on climate change
it's something he's been speaking about
an awful lot previously as well but
prince charles really uh stole the show
in some ways he praised his mother for
her service to the country uh calling
her at one point mummy let's have a
quick listen to what charles had to say
your majesty
mommy
the scale of this evening celebration
and the outpouring of warmth and
affection
over this whole jubilee weekend
is our way
of saying thank you
thank you from your family
the country
the commonwealth
in fact the whole world
on behalf of us all
i wanted to pay my own tribute
to your lifetime of selfless service
in pictures
in words
and in light
[Applause]
your your family
now
four generations
you are our head of state
and you are also
our mother
your strength and stay
is much missed this evening
but i am sure he is here in spirit
my papa would have
enjoyed the show
and
joined us wholeheartedly
in celebrating
all you continue to do
for your country
and your people
looking back
we think
of the countless state occasions that
are milestones along this nation's
road and you
will think of red boxes
filled with government papers
at the end of the day
you will remember
those who have led this country
indeed all the countries you serve
and leaders
across the entire world
how things have changed
we think of all you have done
to make the commonwealth
such an important force for good
you continue to make history
and there was still time for fun amongst
the work
we might
have been celebrating that derby winner
this evening
[Applause]
next year perhaps
but i know what really gets my mother up
in the morning
is all of you ladies and gentlemen
all of you watching at home
represented here tonight in this great
audience
your majesty you've been with us in our
difficult times
and
you bring us together
to celebrate moments of pride
joy
and happiness
maybe this year
it really is coming home
you
you have met us and talked with us
you laugh and cry with us
and most importantly
you have been there for us for these
seventy years
you pledged to serve your whole life
you continue to deliver
that
is why we are here
that
is what we celebrate tonight
these pictures
on your house
are the story of your life
and ours
so your majesty
that is why we all say thank you
now
now ladies and gentlemen i know the
queen is watching these celebrations
with much emotion
having i hope finished her marmalade
sandwich
including immense regret that she cannot
be here in person with us this evening
but
windsor castle
is barely 20 miles away
so if we cheer loudly enough
she might
might just hear us
so
let's all join together
what moment that was um and of course
we're going to have lots more moments
later today the culmination of the
four-day festivities because millions of
people are expected to attend street
parties for the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations braving the rain which i
have to say it does look like it might
not be far off the big jubilee lunch is
the brainchild of the eden project so
we're joined now by the head of uk
delivery at the eden project uh
community communities tracy robbins i
get my words out there still a bit early
i need another cup of coffee i think um
so talk to me a bit about the big lunch
what's the idea so the big lunch was as
you say a brainchild of eden project and
it was all about just trying to get
people and their neighbours to come
together over lunch so people tend to
need permission or reason to knock on
their neighbor's door and come together
and we know when people come together
good things happen
so we just thought how do we
take that message of eden connecting
people to each other in the living world
out to the nation and we use the big
lunch and a lot of people have signed up
to this yeah and the numbers were pretty
astonishing if you look through them
they're incredible so this is the second
time in our history that we've
underpinned the jubilee and so we're
really really proud that the platinum
the
platinum jubilee big lunch is part of
the official celebrations and normal on
a normal year we'll have seven to twelve
thousand pack requests we've had a
hundred thousand pack requests this year
i don't know what we'd do without the
lottery it's been immense and people are
saying oh we think they'll be 12 million
now it's 15. i think the rain holds off
we're looking at 18 percent 18 million i
think so that's a big big proportion and
of course you've got the official you
know packs but obviously millions of
people around the country are gonna be
having unofficial
parties lunches street parties well it
doesn't matter whether it's official or
unofficial if people are coming together
they're joining in and what we have to
remember is this is a once-in-a-lifetime
occasion none of us
will see another platinum jubilee not
even children and i think it's where
memories and connections are made you
know so the legacy will live on from
this definitely yeah yeah
my i just hearing my ear uh the director
just saying sort of the director the
producer just saying his five-year-old
wanted a tea party with her dollies and
i think that just says story just handed
just but it does it does just sum it up
doesn't it yeah
everyone wants to celebrate in any way
that they can and all of these different
ways of
paying tribute to the queen and also
having a bit of a celebration are really
legitimate and it can be really small
you know so we always say the big in the
big lunch or the big jubilee lunch is us
all doing it together at the same time
you know actually it could be you and
ten neighbours or you and three
neighbors it doesn't matter it's about
joining together and just joining in
this occasion that said uh there are
going to be a few big oh there's some on
your occasions
anything in particular put your eye on
um well i think winds are doing they're
gonna go for the longest uh sort of
street um afternoon tea which i think
will be quite spectacular in preston
we've got about 10 000 people coming out
today
um we've got in markham where i was on
thursday they're looking at doing a 2.5
kilometer stretch of table so they're
going for the longest one and they're
expecting about 5 000 people join in um
in this skilling the castle
is doing a whole big display and
encouraging everybody to come so there's
absolutely loads of stuff happening in
all four nations
and it does feel like it's a bit of a
tradition doesn't it and this is
something that has been going on you
know all the way back to the 50s the 60s
i think we can show you some images
perhaps of um the big lunches and the
street parties of the past as well it
does feel like a very british tradition
doesn't it yeah and i think not just
british but across the whole uk so um
and i think we're even seeing them
happening across the commonwealth so
people really want to be um that sense
of belonging and all doing the same
thing at the same time
um i think people love to celebrate and
what are your own plans then well i'll
after this i'll be bobbing along to the
oval so we've got a flagship jubilee big
lunch hosted there with all the platinum
jubilee volunteers and people have made
amazing changes in communities where
they live and we have a special guest
their royal highnesses prince charles
and camilla
so yes so i'm really looking forward to
that yeah pretty good well i have to say
whether it's you know prince charles and
camilla or if it's the dolls around the
table i think you know whatever way lots
of people celebrating
in style uh later let's hope the weather
holds off thank you very much for uh
coming on the project thank you today
well let's talk about that all important
weather uh shall we and see how it is
looking for all of those street parties
[Music]
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the northern parts of the country
will stay mostly fine today but there
will be some showery outbreaks elsewhere
some will be heavy and thundery the
northwest will be clear and chilly at
first with a patchy ground frost but it
will be mostly cloudy and mild elsewhere
with some heavy showers i'm afraid in
the south so north doing better than the
south when it comes to those street
parties uh the northern parts will have
a mainly fine morning
today for the street parties once that
low cloud burns off
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
[Music]
well it's hard to really believe that
the big show took place at here just
last night we're going to have a look at
all the jubilee coverage in the morning
papers of the big event
[Music]
hello welcome back to sky news's
coverage of the jubilee right here from
buckingham palace time now to have a
look at this morning's newspapers we'll
see what they've made of the
celebrations so far joining us once
again is tessa dunlop the royal
historian so we're going to be looking
through the papers together but let's
just show you the uh main headline
starting with the telegraph it
photographs the queen's tea party with
paddington bear which featured of course
in last night's special concert that's
also the image on the front page of the
times today it calls the event the party
of a lifetime for the world's
grandmother
marmalade your majesty asked the
mail on sunday
and the sun on sunday goes with intruder
at the palace making light of paddington
bears surprise appearance there
alongside the queen
let's have a look now at the sunday
express that quotes prince charles's
speech from last night's concert thank
you for being there for us mummy
the sunday mirror features the other
queen of last night brian may who
performed for the royals in front of
buckian palace
and the observer
describes the jubilee festivities as a
long weekend
and a carnival of memory it's quite a
nice phrase that isn't a carnival of
memory well let's have a little look in
more depth now shall we at some of the
stories in
the papers uh tessa thanks for being
with us paddington is on the front of
nearly every paper isn't it today it's a
gift and he has international uh appeal
paddington as does the queen so this is
something that's going to once again
beam britain beyond our borders and i
thought quite a clever opener you know
the first half hour when the we kiddies
stay up you know to see the queen and
obviously an anticipation that she
probably wasn't going to be there in
person and so something needed to be
pre-recorded and capitalizing on that
wonderful olympic appearance when she
jumped out of the was a helicopter or an
airplane i think oh
i think it was a helicopter yeah
but anyway she's really kind of got into
that groove hasn't she and we've come to
love her it's been great and i'm the
kind of person who i kind of find these
things slightly cringe if i'm being
honest but i thought it was actually on
the money and it was really cute um and
yeah it got me actually i thought it was
really lovely yeah and partly because
her fragility was on display that's true
yeah you know she's a seriously old
woman i work predominantly with women
the queen's age
and
there is something almost beautiful
because you realize nothing goes on
forever and there's extremely precious
those final few years and i think that's
what she looks she look really precious
yeah she did she did well let's have a
look at the next uh paper uh shall we uh
this is the are we going to the times
next what's next
next exactly and actually this is
interesting the headlines and the on the
times party of a lifetime for the
world's grandmother and i think that
actually does tap into what you were
saying the fragility on display with her
with the little sketch with paddington
and it does i guess
it does it just enhance people's
affection for her it does and it's a
reminder of how rarely we see people of
extreme old age we have
over half a million non-nigerians in
this country but very rarely are they
front and center of anything and one of
the reasons is of course for health and
the difficulties of actually getting
somebody from a to b one of the old
veterans who was in the same service as
the queen she came down to celebrate
from selby it was a magnus opus you know
just to cross the country it is a big
deal so it is i think that's one of the
really important things about this
latter stage of her reign is that she's
become this symbol of continuity but
also of old age a celebration if you
like and just how much effort it does
take and we need to recognize that
what's interesting here we have the
world's grandmother and the affection
the outpouring michelle obama had a
message for her we've heard people like
macron who's not big on the british yeah
i was quite surprised to see that
actually it's true just showing how
neutral she is she's like the
switzerland of britain if you like makes
mixing my metabolism yeah but i i think
when did this happen this great
rehabilitation if you think how bad the
90s were you see this is interesting
isn't it because it's easy to think that
we always had this affection for the
queen and she could always do no wrong
but actually she did go through these
more difficult periods it's really
difficult and i think that's when we
look at her relationship with i think 14
prime ministers now or is it 13 uh
probably the one she doesn't hold and
dearest affection is tony blair and
there was this tension a slight sense
that is the prime minister staring the
queen trying to bring her down to
buckingham palace in the wake of diana's
death and and the queen finding her way
then as we all were and there was a
transition from the anna's horrible list
terrible death of diana in 97 and then
the golden jubilee there was a gear
change somehow she emerged in that
jubilee as this symbol of endurance
of and again not perfect but who is yeah
it's true yeah who is the beginning of
the national treasure stage of her life
the sunday express uh has got that quote
from prince charles's quite moving
speech i thought actually thank you for
being there for us mummy and i guess
that taps into what you were saying
doesn't that the endurance of the queen
the fact that
in a period where it feels as if society
has just changed so much over the last
70 years she has been the constant yeah
and also what's been demanded of her
as the head of an institution that is
all about preserving tradition
preserving the myths around nationhood
actually being a break in some ways on
sort of unfettered progress
to have
lived through and led through an era
that's never seen such great change for
women alone
we wouldn't we wouldn't have been here
that's true
it's a bit of a check isn't it actually
you realize how much she has like yeah
how much she has lived through and how
much has just changed in that time just
quite incredible and just to go back to
william switch earlier i ribbed him a
bit he said you know mankind put man on
the moon when he was referring to what
the change she'd lived through and i
thought i should have said humankind
william he corrected it later he said
but actually it was mainly men who put
man on the moon it was and there was a
reason that mankind on the moon that man
on the moon that you know that is just a
normal way that we that we spoke then uh
finally let's just have a quick look at
the uh observer and i think it's
interesting isn't it we were just
talking
before we came on air about the
rehabilitation not only the queen but
also the flag yeah because it was
hijacked by brexit i think for a long
time the english frat flag felt like a
sort of symbol of
almost jingoism didn't if you saw it
flying in a garden the red and white it
was like
what's going on there and the the
british union jack always felt more
flexible and inclusive and
that was put in jeopardy with brexit to
an extent i think it became a sort of
political campaigning motif and we've i
think this jubilees reclaimed the union
jack into a more neutral space that even
the labour party want a bite off and i
guess uh the pro-brexit supporters would
say that they used the flag and
patriotism in a way that perhaps the
establishment if you like had become
uncomfortable with and and the fact that
it was popular clearly with a big
proportion of the population that seems
to be what labour party in the kirsten
we're trying to tap into now yeah it's
interesting that but i think because
brexit seems certainly north of the
border is a very english
vote or english decision that i think
that kind of tainted the union japs
jack's ability to speak to all four
nations of course the royal family very
keen to do you notice yesterday i mean
the the cambridges were out in wales one
minute and back at the palace the next
how did they get there jumbo jet
but yeah this is interesting i think
labour clearly recognizing and this this
a labor paper the observer which
historically has always had the sort of
tinge of republicanism once again
guardian observer going um for the full
frontal on on jubilee coverage they've
kind of capitulated haven't they they're
like we can't compete with the queen
yeah there we go and it does feel
doesn't it that uh even people who are
you know staunchly republican and i'm
sure there are many people who you know
have
mixed feelings shall we say about the
royal family particularly after some of
the difficult headlines more recently
the queen is held in affection isn't she
yeah and we've seen that even when the
sussexes are criticizing the firm they
very carefully make an exception of the
firm's ceo which is
yeah paradoxical uh arguably you know
what they're one and the same but they
always say you know we're not talking
about the queen love the queen so she is
okay and that's the gift of not saying
too much and thank you so much talking
about not saying too much we have to uh
go to the break lots more still to come
on sky news breakfast
[Music]
you